[Music]
on this sunday night
bracing for a massive wave of covet
patients
the doctors and nurses shifting gears
preparing for things to get worse
the icu is a nightmare
a nightmare with angels working in it
and the special order to get health
professionals from other provinces
into ontario to help india's devastating
surge
the need for life-saving oxygen and the
countries ready to step
up the threat of a strike at the port of
montreal
and the federal government's 11th hour
solution plus
europe's big clubs thought they were a
big deal
until it all fell apart
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us the third wave is hitting canada
with full force across the country the
rate of active cases remains higher than
it has been
throughout most of the pandemic the good
news is that nearly 11 million people
have received at least one dose of a
coven 19 vaccine
that's about 29 percent of the
population the case numbers however
are still going up with nearly 7 000
positive tests reported today keep in
mind not all provinces report on the
weekend
in the coming weeks doctors and nurses
are preparing for more hospitalizations
and more icu admissions because as mike
delay explains
kofit 19 can cut life short in an
instant
warren montgomery had become a fixture
in regina's food scene
with his louisiana style cooking
everybody his wife rochelle says
seemed to know and love him and now
they'll all likely want to go to his
funeral
after a short and painful fight with
covet 19. he was coughing so hard till
he would throw up
and then once that would happen like he
couldn't breathe he couldn't catch his
breath
it got to the point where he couldn't
say a sentence like he had to struggle
with each word
the montgomeries and their two daughters
all contracted the virus
but it was worn that got hit the hardest
in the span of a week he went from a
positive test
to the icu i stayed with him and
it was only a matter of minutes and uh
he was gone
it was just like he went to sleep um
he was peaceful it was quiet the 42 year
old's case is not dissimilar to what
doctors are seeing in hospitals across
the country
younger and far sicker patients a
snapshot of coveted in canadian
hospitals
paints a troubling picture the latest
data shows a 22 percent
increase in hospitalizations week over
week while icu cases
increased 21 percent ontario continues
to be the hot spot in the country
but bc alberta and saskatchewan are all
seeing record numbers of
hospitalizations
and in atlantic canada nova scotia
hospitals are prepping for new patients
after recording its highest number of
daily cases since the pandemic began
how are you doing doctor strength thanks
for your browsing my life
i'm a little nervous nova scotia's
premier and top doctor
couldn't hide their anxiety nor their
anger at residents who have been hosting
large parties
but the current fine does not seem to be
enough of a deterrent
so we're doubling our fines from one
thousand to two thousand dollars
what they don't want is to become
another ontario where virtually the
entire medical system is geared towards
treating coven 19 patients
toronto's mount sinai hospital recently
opened up a third icu
and now really the biggest problem is
you know we've created this capacity
but it's really a human resource issue
right we just don't have enough people
to be able to care for all these
patients
ontario's premier requested nursing help
from atlantic canada
but it looks like they may soon be busy
microlight global news toronto
the ontario government has approved an
order to bring in health professionals
from other provinces
to help the growing number of cova
patients in hospital
the emergency measure also allows nurses
within ontario to provide care that's
under their regular scope of practice
but as catherine ward reports critics
worry there could be troubling
consequences
as hospitals fill as a new surge of
covet 19 takes hold
nurses are shouldering professional and
personal burdens like never before
my heart breaks at work my heart breaks
when i get home the bonds
nurses and patients share has become
even more critical with the pandemic you
know last week i was
literally just rubbing my patient's head
and
you know letting her know that
the daughter said she loves her a new
order issued to ontario
civil servants and unions last week
under the emergency management and civil
protection act
referenced here in this memo will allow
health care professionals including
nurses to provide
patient care services outside their
regular scope of practice and also
enables hospitals to employ
contract appoint or otherwise engage
regulated health professionals from out
of province
this provision only applies to nurses
working in hospitals and only
to prevent or alleviate the effects of
the kubi19
outbreak the province says the goal for
these measures is
simple help reduce administrative burden
and allow
hospitals to focus on delivering patient
care while at the same time
building up the province's health care
workforce the province says workers will
not be asked to perform
tasks they aren't qualified for some
experts say there are still
concerns if in the rush of doing things
that rpn will do things that she or he
is not competent to do
that nurse could be reported to the
college of nurses
in an interview with the canadian press
health minister christine elliott says
more than 40 health care workers from
outside ontario have already volunteered
and more could be on the way
arriving as early as this week but some
critics remain skeptical
number of nurses arrest with icu
training or critical care training that
will come from other
jurisdictions in our view will be
minimal still for those feeling the
pressure in hospitals across ontario
many know nurses are the key to ensure
things run
as smoothly as possible even under
challenging circumstances catherine ward
global news toronto india
is in a crisis with kova 19 spreading
beyond its control
it's believed a new variant of the virus
is driving case numbers
up today the country reported nearly 350
000
cases the world's highest daily toll
since the start of the pandemic
overburdened hospitals are turning
patients away because
oxygen tanks and beds are in short
supply
so there's even greater urgency to get
citizens vaccinated
in a country which has 18 percent of the
world's population
as jennifer johnson reports india is
calling on the u.s
to send help as india reports over 300
000 new cases of code 19 a day
hospitals are being forced to turn away
the sick and dying
the indian government is rushing oxygen
to overwhelmed medical centers by planes
and trains
but there isn't enough doctors are now
appealing to the world for
help when you walk outside the hospitals
and you see that rush and
people calling frantic calls you know
crying on the phone that please can you
help me for a bed and all that i can say
is yes i'm trying
who would ever think there would be a
shortage of oxygen to breathe
it's like terrible ventilators are being
packed into trucks from the uk
heading for india the aim is to provide
the support that the indians need at
their hour of need really
if judging by the distressing scenes
we've seen
the u.s government is also pledging to
send aid immediately
there's discussions about really ramping
up what we can do on the ground
oxygen supplies drugs tests
ppe as well as taking a look in the
intermediate and long run about how we
can get vaccines to these individuals
crematories are overloaded with corpses
desperate residents are searching on the
black market for oxygen tanks
and the kovitt treatment drogram
desevere any weapon to save their lives
or their loved ones
we are facing a deep crisis the smaller
hospitals
are getting closed because of the
supply chain issue of oxygen and more
and more burden
is coming on the larger hospitals india
thought the worst of the pandemic was
over
restrictions had been lifted the
government even allowed this huge hindu
festival earlier this month
but now people are dying in the streets
in this second wave
the cases are increasing exponentially
there is cascity of beds there is costly
of oxygen
this costly of everything less than two
percent of india's population is fully
vaccinated against cova 19.
it is currently administering about 3
million doses a day but
some areas have run out of vaccine
supplies
as this deadly surge continues to spread
jennifer johnson global news
washington and if things couldn't get
worse
a fire has torn through a hospital in
baghdad that was treating covet 19
patients
at least 82 people died and 110 others
were injured
there are reports that began when an
oxygen cylinder
exploded inside an icu at least 28
patients on ventilators
are among the dead the wreckage of an
indonesian navy submarine has been
located
split in three pieces underwater footage
shows the fragmented vessel
800 meters below the surface of the bali
sea
all 53 crew members on board died the
sub went missing wednesday during a
torpedo drill
more than a thousand dock workers are
ready to walk off the job at canada's
second largest port
the port of montreal handles about 275
million dollars worth of goods
every day and any disruption could cost
the economy
25 million dollars a day but as mike
armstrong reports
the federal government is trying to
avert economic disaster
[Music]
with the strike deadline looming the
federal government is
stepping in dock workers at the port of
montreal planned to walk off the job
monday morning
but there is now back to work
legislation
set to be tabled the announcement came
in a series of tweets from the federal
labor minister philomena tassie says the
government tried for two and a half
years to help with a negotiated
settlement
and calls back to work legislation the
government's least favorite option
but tasi says a work stoppage at the
port in the middle of a pandemic
would be too big a blow to canada's
economy the news has business groups
hoping
they've avoided a crisis we've been
asking the federal government to step in
for many weeks now so we're very pleased
to see
that they are willing to intervene and
ensure that there is a full
that the port of montreal is fully
operational
the port's 1150 dock workers have been
without a collective agreement since
december of 2018.
they walked off the job for 11 days last
summer before agreeing to a truce
in recent weeks negotiations got bumpy
dock workers went on an overtime strike
they're refusing to work weekends
the management group the maritime
employers association
in response said last week it was
changing
work shifts longshoremen's union friday
called that a provocation
the only way we could answer that is to
put a general strike
for monday the work stoppage last summer
cost the canadian economy more than
half a billion dollars it didn't even
last two weeks but the backlog was so
big
it took three months to catch up a new
strike
would be devastating for the economy the
small
museum businesses are already on the
ground
according to a source the union has sent
out picket assignments for monday
morning that hasn't changed
back to work legislation would still
have to be tabled debated
and adopted with the minority government
it would also need
support from other parties to pass
mike armstrong global news montreal
coming up the real estate buying frenzy
and the crisis facing
young people
[Music]
a reckless driver in albania's capital
drove through a blockade and
into a crowded square but his antics
screeched to a halt
when a daredevil jumps through the car
window to stop the vehicle
police believe the driver was under the
influence of marijuana
the incident happened during the
country's election but it's unclear
if there's a link home prices are
skyrocketing across the country
that's good news for sellers but for
first-time buyers the dream of owning a
home
is starting to feel like a fantasy
housing analysts say canada has an
affordability crisis
one that could have long-term
consequences here's our senior business
correspondent
ann gaviola andres penalosa and his wife
have been looking to buy a home in the
vancouver area
since they immigrated to canada from
venezuela in 2018.
we've seen the bidding wars we've seen
houses selling
way over asking price and it's it's just
very discouraging
they're part of a cohort of young
workers under the age of 35
increasingly shut out of the housing
market a generation whose earnings have
now suffered through two recessions
and even though mortgage rates are
historically low prices are on a tear
real estate broker bethany king says in
addition to a lack of supply prospective
home buyers aren't competing on a level
playing field
they're up against buyers who have built
up a lot of equity over the years
first-time buyers are competing with
baby boomer
cash they are downsizing and often going
into those
smaller single family homes that would
normally be reserved for
our first time home buyers with home
prices across canada surging more than
31 percent
in march economists have been calling on
politicians to cool the market
we need our hearts and our heads to lean
in to the idea that we have an
affordability crisis and we cannot have
an affordable place to call home also be
an exceptionally good return on
investment
a recent report by the bank of montreal
called on ottawa to do something to
break the market's psychology and the
buying frenzy fueled by a desire for
more space
and a fear of missing out critics say
policy response has been muted there are
new tougher mortgage stress test rules
set to kick in in june
and in this week's federal budget there
was new money to increase the supply of
affordable housing and an empty homes
tax but no further measures to cool the
housing market
and in the recent ontario and bc budgets
housing was not a priority
some say as long as the wealthiest
canadians depend on their homes as an
investment vehicle
measures to douse the red hot housing
market will remain politically
untouchable
home ownership is more out of reach for
a growing part of our population
and that means we need to change our
hearts and minds about not in my
backyard we need to welcome more rentals
and co-ops in our neighborhoods move
beyond nimbyism to say yes in my
backyard
ann gaviola global news toronto
still ahead of federal election in a
pandemic we'll show you how you may end
up voting
preparations are underway for a
potential federal election
with the minority government in power it
could happen at any time
mail-in ballots will be key to a safe
and successful vote
elections canada is preparing for as
many as 5 million canadians to use a
mail-in ballot
if there is an election this year that
would be historic
because it would be a hundred times more
mail-in balance than any other general
election
david aiken walks us through the process
so this is the package this is the
package this is what we call
a special ballot kit and you only get
one
if you ask for one unlike in the u.s or
elsewhere
no ballot in canada is automatically
mailed to you
new this year going online to ask for
your mail-in ballot
you will still need identification
though it's the same thing as when you
go to the polls you need to prove
who you are and you need to prove where
you live elections canada reviews your
request
there is a physical person on the other
end who will
check to make sure that that your your
id
uh is good to go at the heart of the
package you will then get in the mail
is the actual ballot that's the actual
that's the actual ballot it says
specimen it's not a real ballot but
look it'll be this uh color this grayish
color
it's also blank you will be expected to
know
the first name and last name of the
candidate you want to vote for
and you have to write that in here you
cannot just put in the party
so if you just write you know purple
let's say we have a purple party and a
plaid party yeah you put plaid party
your ballot will not be counted you then
take your ballot
and put it in envelope a that's an
envelope that has no identifying marks
on it
envelope a goes into envelope b
this is the envelope you have to sign
and date and if you don't do that your
ballot will get thrown out
envelope b goes into envelope c postage
is prepaid
now just drop this in a mailbox no
envelopes will be open until
after the polls close on election night
and each one will be opened by hand
and counted by hand no machines are used
and that's a process that will take time
people
should be prepared to expect delays in
the results
and we may not know the final results of
the election on election night
and the mail-in ballots just like every
other kind of ballot cast in an election
are by law stored in this election's
canada warehouse for
10 years a complete paper record
of a pandemic election david aiken
global news
ottawa up next while the european super
league has everyone
offside
when 12 of europe's most successful
soccer clubs plotted to join a breakaway
competition less than a week ago
the move kicked off the sport's biggest
crisis
in half a century the european super
league was only
open to a handful of the world's
wealthiest football teams
owners envisioned a bigger bottom line
but they didn't anticipate the
fastest collapse of a colossal business
scheme
critics say the competition was driven
by greed
fans fifa and europe's governing body
are still fuming
and as eric sorensen reports the game
isn't over
the super league the biggest clubs in
soccer playing for billions of dollars
what's not to like well for one
a lot of fans like these at chelsea
instantly hated the idea that rich clubs
could get richer
while abandoning the teams they used to
play from
england this is rome to spain why they
don't do it
it's only for the rich rich clubs and
more money the super league was to
include the six biggest teams from
england's premier league three top teams
from italy
and the three powerhouses from spain
clubs like man you
and barcelona currently generate massive
revenues that help smaller teams
the super league would bring just the
big teams together
with backing from banks lucrative tv
contracts
and their own deep pockets chelsea is
owned by a russian billionaire
manchester city by a member of the abu
dhabi royal family
juventus by an italian industrialist
soccer has to evolve said real madrid
president florentino perez
favoring the league new competition
would generate more interest and more
income
but the backlash was swift outside
liverpool
stadium banners denounced the new super
league
brighton players wore protest t-shirts
the league flying in the face of history
where teams earned their way into
international competition
it's not competitive it's a closed shot
you can't
have a competition where no one else is
allowed in
soccer's establishment rebelled the
ultimate aim
for some is no longer to decorate the
club's trophy cabinet with silverware
but to fill the bank account with cash
and politicians vowed legislation to
block the venture
it's not in the interests of fans it's
not in the interests of
football cracks began to appear
manchester city
backed out then the rest of the english
teams and within two days the entire
enterprise that seemed founded on greed
imploded from the spanish league
president
the super league as it was conceived he
said is dead
liverpool's owner issued an abject
apology to fans
i'm sorry and i alone am responsible for
the
unnecessary negativity brought forward
over the past couple of days
and with that the new super league
vanished like a bad dream
liverpool players were back on the pitch
atletico madrid seemed happy to be back
to normal
and those chelsea fans were on the
streets again but this time
chanting we saved football
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is dorchester
ontario
thank you for watching donna friesen
we'll be back at the anchor desk
tomorrow and i'll see you next weekend
have a great night
[Music]
you